hot breath we were discussing the right
ten with uh
on uh in a group and i said uh it's a
a really cool thing because you have to
you have a time frame right you have 10
minutes and you're given one word
and so the challenge is on it really
forces you to get creative
now rather than getting lazy with it and
letting it go
right and then yeah okay never mind i
wasn't able to do anything
but it's like 10 minutes and you sort of
gamify it and people put their stuff up
on
you know on twitter yeah and we started
doing
a uh it's funny you said embarrassment
as well because we started doing a
monthly joke writing contest where
people get
a random emotional theme and then they
get seven days to create a new
90-second set based on that emotional
theme
so and then um there's three judges that
will judge and then we have a finale
that live streams into this group and
all that
so that's like another constriction
that's more like a motion driven which
is where a lot of the best material
comes from
right awesome well that's um yeah that
that was very helpful for me
and also the checklist that's so funny
because there is a tab in the facebook
group that says like uh it's like
writing resources and i think that
checklist is number one
so we'll go and tag you in it
that's very funny so yeah i mean if you
think about it
and in a general joke you know one
word's a little different than
say a sentence or a fact right because
the fact usually puts it into a premise
so if i have a fact or you know a
statement about me
i have five kids then i can go through
that
my checklist my first checklist would be
there's a three uh three questions i
asked the
the line would be is there an assumption
expectation or image that i can shatter
that'd be number one number two would be
are there two dissimilar ideas
converging right
so uh i have five kids um not really
so but there is an assumption there i
have five kids
uh so you there's an expectation so i
or you and there is an impossible
incongruity if i force it if i
add one later like i have five kids
because i'm only half mormon
um then then you have something like
that right so then you can go on from
there i have five kids from three
different moms
and they go look there's the judgment
right there did you hear that right you
could feel that and then you
comment on that right so you but so the
question number one is uh
is there an expectation an image or an
assumption that i can shatter
is there a double entendre play here
meaning is there a second meaning of the
word
uh or an alternate comedic meaning of
the word that i can play with
or is there are there two dissimilar
ideas converging
so once i go through those that say i
wasn't able to come up with anything
i'll say is there could i come up with a
cliche related to the
this this phrase this word um that i can
reform
you know um you know so if i looked up i
can just quickly look up cliches
now i have like three cliches and i can
try to reform those cliches
uh doing so a cliche reformation is when
you
basically are stating a cliche and
everybody knows the ending
and you change the ending because
they're already it's like it's almost
like dice man with uh
limericks right everybody knew the
ending they were already saying the
ending
right so you create that expectation the
brain already creates that ending you
flip that ending
whatever happens in vegas stays in vegas
whatever happens vegas you know so if
you give it context whatever happens
my sister just had a baby because
whatever happens in vegas evidently
comes out of your vagina
um so that was written by in a class by
one of my students
uh pauline yasuda and that joke still
gets big labs
you know so but you know you these
concepts you can apply then you could do
an
or an analogy you can drop in um then
you look for a paradox
um so these are things that people laugh
at that don't have punch lines
paradoxical humor
because it causes the brain to do a
little dance you know
that's a funny way to say it brain a
little dance
well yeah you have to write you when you
do paradox it causes you to
because a paradox is when you take
something that sounds like it
shouldn't be true but you find out that
it can be true
or when you have two things that can be
true but not true at the exact same
time like the word prick right so prick
and prick like george carlin's joke you
realize on tv you can say you pricked
your finger but you can't say you
fingered your prick
so by definition prick and prick those
are two
things because that can be true but not
true at the exact same time
and when you run them so close together
it's pretty much the exact same moment
you know in the in the in the scheme of
things when you're performing and people
do that little damn oh you're right
i never thought about it that way
so that's the dance right they recognize
and go how come i never
it's right there in front of my face
you